moi le chant a toujours été important pour
moi mais je n'ai jamais pensé que nos finissent par
chanter
je pense juste que j'ai de la chance il y a
quelque chose que je peux toujours faire si je le
veux j'ai tellement de chance comme
ça  sortait le temps
qui me représentait vraiment ou la façon dont je
me sentais, donc je vous savez, j'aime juste pourquoi
j'écrirais n'importe quoi à moins que ce ne soit
directement personnel pour moi juste parce
que je ne serais pas capable de raconter l'histoire,
je ne le suis pas  une fille essayant d'être une star ou
essayant d'être autre chose qu'une
musicienne quelle taille pensez-vous que vous
allez être je ne pense pas que je
vais être je lui ai dit cinq souris je ne sais pas
je pense que je pourrais gérer je deviendrais probablement
fou tu sais je veux dire je deviendrais fou
c'est dur de savoir anxieux ouais